-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy and Golden Globe
award-winning actress you know
from such shows as
"Mad Men," "The West Wing,
and "The Handmaid's Tale."
She stars in
"The Invisible Man,"
which is in theaters
and IMAX on February 28th.
Let's take a look.
♪♪♪♪
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Please welcome back to the sho
Elisabeth Moss, everybody!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is -- As movie clips go
that was very intense.
-Oh, good.
The rest of the movie
is just kind of slow.
-Yeah, it's very chill.
It's a very chill movie about an
invisible man.
-Pretty much.
-Yeah.
It's interesting, because a lo
of times in horror movies,
people are dealing with CGI,
but, like, this is --
The man's invisible.
So you were doing
a lot of acting
that we, as an audience,
are doing,
because you can't see anybod
'cause no one's there.
-Right. Very true.
That was with the incredible
stuntperson, though.
So, yeah, and a
harness and the whole thing.
-Gotcha. How many times
did you have to do
the old harness scene?
-I think that we did like
five or six times --
-Okay, so that's not crazy
Yeah. Well...
-Oh, really?
-I was never in movies.
I don't know.
Six seems normal.
-Yeah, yeah.
I am not a
very physical person, so -
-Gotcha.
-Yes.
-Is there a lot of discussio
about doing your own stunt
with a film like this?
-Yes. So, Leigh,
our wonderful writer/director,
called me while I was
in Toronto, and he said,
"I want you to do
as much as possible,
you know, if you're game.
Like, I'm feeling it out."
And I was like,
"Yeah, totally, man.
Like, let's totally do that.
I want to do as many stunt
as I can."
And then I kind of forgot abou
it for like a month.
And then I got to Australia,
where we shot it,
and we started going to
set rehearsals,
and I was like, "Oh, no.
No, no, no."
Like, I don't
like going to the gym.
I don't like working out.
-Yeah. Right.
-Like, napping is
my physical activity.
-Yeah. It's a good one.
-It is a sport.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think it's healthy.
I think napping's very healthy
-It is very healthy.
-Yeah.
-Thank you very much.
-So, I had to do
all these stunts
and these stunt rehearsals
and I had to do lots of running.
There's so much running.
-Yeah.
-It was constantly running
-They think the invisible ma
won't be fast,
but he's a regular man.
He's just invisible.
-Exactly.
-He's right on your heels.
And you have no idea
how much gap you have
between you and him.
-You don't know where he is.
-You can't be like,
"I can slow down now.
I got some,
yeah, space between us."
-You don't know.
-I feel like you've done -
I feel like "Handmaid's"
has some running, as well.
-It does.
-There's been some,
like, running in the woods
-There was a lot of runnin
in the woods.
-I feel like the
last season particularly,
it was like, "Let's really run
in the woods."
-We have to stop this.
-Yeah.
-This is not my thing.
-It feels like the
"Handmaid's" universe needs Uber
for you.
Just for you.
I don't know it will perfectly
fit into the story line.
-Just for me.
Or just, like, a slow walk
Remember the days when I used to
just slowly walk on the show
-Yeah.
-That was lovely.
-I mean, now that
you mention it,
I feel like a lot of
the first couple seasons
were a lot of slow walking
-Yeah.
-It was like a lot of the
exposition happened on walks
It was lovely.
If you didn't know what the show
was about, you'd be like,
"This is a nice show.
-This is a wonderful show,
a lot of two-hander scenes
of us just walking and talking
-A lot of, like, happy women
who coincidentally wore
the same outfit.
That's always funny.
So, this is -- The origina
"Invisible Man" movie, I think
was in the '30s, right?
-Yes, 1933.
-And had you seen those films?
-I hadn't.
-I actually never watched
any of them.
But I'm a huge horror fan.
-Was that something
you got into as a kid?
-Oh, yeah.
When I was 11 or 12,
I used to get together
with my girlfriends,
and we'd have sleepovers
and we'd watch scary movies,
which now seems really bad
-Yeah.
-Like, why did we do that?
It's a terrible idea.
But we'd just scare the [bleep
out of ourselves.
-I know. We did it, too.
I also think there was
a really fun thing that --
And, again,
this makes sound old,
and I appreciate people
will feel that.
But, like, going to select the
from a video store
was also sort of thrilling
-Absolutely.
-Because the covers of the
were terrifying.
-Yes. And curating that wa
all very exciting,
and you'd get your two
for the night, you know,
and then settle in.
-Like, that's when
I realize I'm older,
because the idea -- I used t
watch two movies a night
all the time.
If I get 15 minutes into
anything before falling asleep
it is incredible.
-I know.
-I never --
I was so scared by the idea,
I've still not seen
"Nightmare on Elm Street."
-Really?
-And I like scary movies.
-Oh, it's a good one.
-Yeah.
-But there was just somethin
about that guy's face.
I was like, "No, thank you."
-You didn't like it.
-Yeah, it was like, "I do no
care for your choices."
-It's not a good face.
-I do not like your grooming
and I'm not going to spend
two hours with you.
-I like what you've done here.